[Music]
joe is in san antonio hi joe how can we
help
how's it going better than i deserve
what's up
so i'm getting married to uh to a
girlfriend of five years this coming
spring
good friend and uh we're both both
completely debt-free she's about to
graduate college and um awesome how old
are you guys
uh both 19. i'm turning 20 in a couple
of days wonderful
and um
and i just wanted to know if it would be
a good idea to gift her six thousand
dollars to fund her ira for this year no
before we're actually combining finances
and married no
no no
it will change
the tenor
and the tone
of your unmarried relationship
you're a guy and you're thinking in math
terms
i'm an old guy
who's been married 40 years and has done
a whole lot of stupid butt stuff
that i didn't know i was stupid when i
was doing it it affected the tenor and
the tone of my relationship and i've had
to go back and clean up a lot of it but
yeah no no no no no no
to you it's just a math problem
to her it's a power play
okay maybe i might be severe or
melodramatic in that
uh it could affect the way her dad feels
could affect the way her mom feels
it might change the way you
sit in a chair when you're discussing
wedding budgets
you see what i'm saying
i see what you're saying you've you've
departmentalized compartmental as this
is a simple mathematical thing over here
to the side which is a very smart
mathematical thing by the way you came
up with a really good idea but you did
not factor in all the negative
relational possible consequences and it
ain't worth it dude you're 19 years old
you got the rest of your freaking life
to get rich and you're going to be so
rich it's going to be unbelievable and
none of it will be because you
pre-funded your fiance before you were
married's
retirement plan when you were 19 years
old that didn't cause you to be rich
what caused you to be rich is you're
smart enough to even ask this question
when you're this age yeah uh pretty
simple there's no upside at all just
wait well there's an upside it's math
yeah math upside's huge well yeah but
there's no relational upside down
relational downside so that means
there's no upside so wait until you get
married then you fully fund her once you
guys get rolling and yeah to their point
they're 19. he's gonna be 20. i mean my
goodness or he is 20. she's 19. so yeah
just stay out of it i love the i love
the question
you know i love i think it shows it
shows he's paying attention yes
god if i was 19 and i paid attention
where would that be right now isn't that
the truth
i did pay attention but it wasn't a
smart to the right things that's right
gave a lot of attention to the wrong
thing
i was enthusiastically stupid
an enthusiastic ignoramus but yeah
that's uh yeah dude you're very smart
it's a very smart and intellectual and
good math question and it mathematically
it would be a beautiful move uh but the
offside is not worth it
and something happens and you got a
problem
so good question thank you for joining
us hey let's let me let me grow on that
just a little bit ken because uh we've
got a ton of folks
young folks in our audience who are uh
pre-married
let's call them pre-married
they they hadn't gotten married yet
and uh when you pay someone's bills that
you're not married to and you're not
unified with
contractually in a covenant in a
spiritual relationship you change the
tenor
of that
the old joke is if you if you loan your
brother-in-law a hundred dollars and he
never speaks to you again was it worth
it
that's the old cause it changes when you
loan people money when you give people
money it changes
the the chemistry now the better the
person the more noble the intent the
less
obvious the change is
but it does change it
and uh and i'm old and i've done this a
long time and so i've seen all the
negative things like we had a guy one
time he paid off a whole bunch of his uh
fiance's debt
and then they bought a house together
before they were married and um
and then um
she died in a car wreck before they were
married
now he owns a house with his
fiancee's mother
and
his fiancee's mother the estate of his
fiancee owes him money
wow for the debt that he paid off
or he loses all that money either one
i mean it's a tragedy upon tragedy upon
tragedy it's so
uh obviously the death in a car wreck
was an unspeakable tragedy
uh and dave you're talking about money
in the middle of something like that no
i'm just talking about the the in the
middle of an unspeakable tragedy we've
got more layers
to the problem rather than just the
tragedy yeah
and so yeah you don't you do not want to
be
owning a house with your mother-in-law
that was never your mother-in-law no
because you never got married
yeah and again all the intentions are
good but it's it's so important that you
keep everything separate until you get
into that married union and now it's we
and and just you're right it change you
know what it does it creates a little
bit of leverage and i think you're right
a mature person a healthy person won't
use that leverage intentionally
intentionally
but boy the leverage is there it
absolutely is there i'm i'm pretty
emotionally mature pretty spiritually
mature i've been doing this stuff a long
time but if i give ten thousand dollars
to something
it changes my you know and it was a
generous gift
and i don't have an expectation of
you know when i walk in the room you bow
down three times or something like that
i don't have anything like that but then
i but then if they um
you know they they
i i don't know slight you in a
conversation yeah
you're much more you're ten thousand
dollars worth are more offended that's
the truth it's exactly you cannot keep
that from happening because it's human
nature and i'm aware of it i teach it
i've written books about this stuff but
but then i find myself in that it's not
that i demand respect or i'm some kind
of arrogant butthole or something like
that that's not the point
that's not but but but you know
you know i've given x numbers of tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousand
dollars to this thing and and then you
go in there and they act like you're not
there
hey that's pretty stupid but um but but
but you know from a just a development
standpoint sure but but aside from that
it's just human nature to say
gosh
they didn't even say thank you yes
you know like i have a relative who um
if you don't send a thank you note
she'll call you
where's my thank you note oh
you know and i i guess
well she's old school right manners mrs
manners the books you know i mean you
should have manners
and say thank you but that comes with
the gift right
and so it's human nature
human nature it changes relationships
the transfer of money does
you can't keep it from happening the
borrower's slave to the lender